I THINK IT WENT OFF THE SHAFT O.
PLAY BACACSIX.
AND HE'LL GET IT OVER THERE.
AND LOOKED LIKE IT WENT OFFJAD.
KREIDER BACK TO ZIBANEJAD.
>> Joe: WE'VE SEEN THIS
LOOKING AND SHOOTING.
HRONEK CROSS CORNER OFF OFF OF
RANGERS IDER -- KREIDER FOR GOO
THE SAVE.OPPED
BACK THE OTHER WAY.
PANARIN.
LOOKED LIKE HE WAS HOOKED ON THE
PLAY.
PASS BLOCKED.
PANARIN HAS IT  ZADINA.
HAD IT KNOCKED AWAY.
ZIBANEJAD WITH IT.
KREI IN FRONT.
STOPPED
WRAPAROUND.
HE SCORES!
OH,JOB.
LOOK AT THE REACH.
THE QUICK MOVE AND THENT REACH.
RIRI HE SCORES!E IS LARKIN.
GOAL NUM22 GAMES.
HE IS R
THEY PUT PRESSURE ON.
THEY KEEP GOING.
THEY SHOW PATIENCE.
AND NOT HAD THE LEAD IN THE G T.
>> HERE'S WHAT DETROIT THINKS OF
TWO MINUTES GO IN THE OVERTIME.
SHOTS ARE 3-1 IN THE
OVERTIME.NET.
LEDDY STAYS WITH HIM.
RIDES HIM TO THE BOARDD.
LARKIN HAS IT.
LARKIN TO FABBRI.SUTER.
WITH HIS FIRST AUST SCORE TO KE.
CHYTIL.
IN